just ask you about some possible
criticisms of Bitcoin so on
centralization so there's a criticism on
the so on the mining and on the Node
side uh or the node is not really the
criticism but Bitcoin mining is not
fully decentralized because a small
number of miners uh control a majority
of the hashing power I looked it up it's
ten thousand fifteen thousand whatever
the number is of of computers they have
the full that are full nodes that have
the full uh that are actively connected
to the network so you could argue that's
decentralized because it's Global it's
all across the world but the miners
they're still
um it's more centralized so if you're
thinking of making a case for Bitcoin
being decentralized do you worry about
the miners being somewhat centralized is
is the nodes the important thing to
think about yeah and and what number of
nodes constant centralized and not
the nodes are what matters because the
nodes are what determines bitcoin's
consensus parameters I think the the
um the the best way to think about it is
that miners simply sell a commodity to
the nodes and that commodity is Bitcoin
blocks so what a minor does is they
solve the proof of work problem so they
keep operating their computers until
they can get a solution to the problem
and then they attach that to a bunch of
transactions and present it to the nodes
for the nodes to ratify and approve it
so therefore uh this is and this is I I
strongly recommend people learn about
the 2017 block size War to understand
why miners don't control Bitcoin I
discussed this uh briefly in my Bitcoin
standard but there's a recent book that
discusses this in detail called The
Block size War by Jonathan beer it's a
great description of
in 2017 essentially the miners thought
that they can control Bitcoin you know
they had there was uh one mining company
that produced the majority of the
machines that were on the network and
they and their allies had a control of
the machines that were out there and
they controlled the majority of the hash
rate and they thought that they could
change bitcoin's uh Supply not supply
sorry they could change bitcoin's block
size which is a the tiny little detail
technical parameter it's not even all
that big of a deal for the economics of
it but they thought that they could pass
this change they could force this change
on the network
and the members of the network rejected
it and they weren't able to do it so the
nodes are what is Sovereign the nodes
are what determine the rules of the game
the miners
are a service provider the miners invest
Capital upfront you know they buy the
machines they buy the electricity they
buy the storage they buy the locations
they pay the rent
and they invest all of that money
based on the idea that if they behave
according to what the nodes want the
nodes will reward them with Bitcoin so
the miners are in no position to dictate
terms for anyone you know they've
they've put up their Capital up front
and they will only recoup it if they do
what the nodes want so therefore what
really matters is the decentralization
of the nodes so we want to we you want
to have as many nodes as possible you
should um you want to have a system
where there's a large number of nodes
and this is of course the biggest
problem with
um
with other digital currencies is that
you know because basically Bitcoin has
cornered the market on a digital
currency the only way that you can
really get traction
um is to generate a whole bunch of
buzzwords but you know we're doing this
and we're doing that and so other
digital currencies are optimized for
um bells and whistles and buzzwords and
that means adding a computational load
which makes the nodes bigger harder to
operate and therefore you have a very
small number of nodes in fact very few
digital currencies are Keen to publicize
how many nodes there are and they don't
have full nodes in the true sense and it
doesn't even matter how many nodes they
have because
um de facto in you know you you can you
can spin up a million nodes tomorrow on
AWS
doesn't really matter what matters is de
facto do the nodes dictate the rules of
consensus and the fact that with most
digital currencies you can have hard
Forks very frequently and they can
change the supply all the time means
that there's a small group of people who
agree amongst themselves how to move
forward yeah so you threw in a few
criticism of all coins there but so one
is the small group that one we could we
could talk about it's a tricky one and
we we talked about that with Satoshi
Nakamoto but the other one is a small
number of nodes that are to push back in
that as computational power increases
you can argue that that enables more and
more uh cheap computers to serve as
nodes so at least it paints a future
where nodes are always increasing
because computational power is always
increasing and getting cheaper and
cheaper cheaper so at least there's a
hope for the future for greater and
greater decentralization
decentralization on the Node front yeah
but I mean ultimately again it doesn't
really matter how many nodes uh you have
if you have a you know if the way that
the currency is run is that you're going
to have a hard Fork every few months
which is the case with most other
currencies Bitcoin is the only one
that's not have the hard Fork
basically the the unique thing about
Bitcoin uh in a technical sense is that
you could get the original software that
Satoshi himself ran in 2009 to start the
network and you could run it today and
it would sync with the blockchain
there's one bug you need to fix
uh one mistake that was on that would
have only appeared I think in around
2013 or 14 or something like that as
that he wasn't aware of back then so you
just need to fix this one tiny little
bug and then the consensus parameters
are still the same so you're able to
sync to it this is not true for most
other digital currencies I'd say
probably all of them because they've all
had many hard forces they think of as
upgrades and you know they they Market
this thing as you know well Bitcoin
can't upgrade but we upgrade all the
time well yeah you know what else
upgrades all the time Facebook Apple
Amazon anything that centralized is very
easy to upgrade and that's precisely why
as Michael Saylor says these things are
somebody's liability they are security
you're carrying on somebody's Tech
Technical and economic liability they
can hard work they can 10x the supply
tomorrow yeah
they can fall victim to the same
corrupting forces that governments of
fall victim to sure and for people who
don't know yeah hard Fork is a uh
reverse incompatible change to uh uh
into the underlying function of a
cryptocurrency
of course there is hard Forks of uh
Bitcoin as well
I'm sure all of which you love dearly
anyway but that doesn't that doesn't
matter the original Bitcoin uh for the
most part is has not undergone any
changes
and that's one of those I mean it has
undergone changes but none uh none in
the uh important parameters of the
network